[Music]
[Music]
luckily the whole shoot in my head it
was all there see all the notes nice not
to get it out it's a little bit funny
this feeling inside would you say your
name was again
my name is Reginald
Dwight's Reginald that's my granddad's
thing that is a fat boy from nowhere get
to be a soul man got to kill the person
you were born to be in order to become
the person you want to be I'm thinking
of changing my name to Elton that's my
name yeah the best-selling artist
America earthly desire who's
traditionally bowel down why are you so
show me flashy
can you even play the piano in those
I know you are
just don't kill yourself with drugs so
how does it feel to be a stop
it's never gonna last just enjoy right
well we can arrange okay one of this is
gone I just hope you realize you're
choosing a knife for being a man forever
don't know why I just sing without this
ridiculous paraphernalia people don't
pay to see which wife they pay to see
Elton John
sorry
[Music]
do you care how much pressure I'm on the
not real I'll still be collecting my 20%
along after you've killed yourself
[Music]
I should have tried to be more ordinary
he would never ought marry
[Music]
most shine little boy you might look at
you now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mom my piano teacher thinks I'm good
enough for a scholarship at the Royal
Academy of Music the Royal Academy of
Music has a nice ring to it
royal scissors what do you think the red
one is good it's only in Saturday's
things to do on weekends can't just drop
everything I'll take you where are you
off to
then I haven't decided yet but whatever
it is you're not invited ready to piano
teacher thinks he's good enough for a
scholarship really you think he's got
that kind of talent of course he has but
you'd know that if you took the
slightest bit of interest in me or this
family don't parent yo 63 it's a good
vintage oh no thanks
it's said always important to rely on
the kindness of strangers
John Reed
Alton they're not all seems a bit
overwhelming at first but something
makes me think you'll get used to it
in fact I predict you could be the best
selling artists in America if you desire
I'll see you like something not quite as
much as the singer bonus whooping yeah
you must be Elton yeah hi where's my
stage name yeah well you can tell me
your name want to get to know each other
better right I see you ever so sorry
no no please see I like your Louis thank
you yeah I got the tip that you sent
that's great really good thanks oh hang
on
hey don't bother with that one that
wasn't supposed to be in there that's
really good all right you into it
yeah hold a song yeah I read it and I
could hear the whole tune in my head it
was all there I could see all the notes
you know I just have to get it out it's
not my fingers couldn't work fast enough
to keep up with my brain do you ever get
anything like that not really now oh I
could write more for you though Elton
I'll just send them down to you great
what do you say your name is again
Elson Terran is an actor of incredible
range no gene baby
[Music]
Alvin said I do I've ever heard anyone
could sing my songs better than Terra
Elton's songs at the defining moments in
people's lives and the songs that should
all come from a place of character
Taran's actually singing in the film
and he's so convincing and his voice is
incredible
I'd Dyson there's anyone in the world to
complaint out its Terrence wrong
[Music]
just bring the greatest joy of my
professional life making his films
[Music]
it's never gonna last
just enjoy it while we can
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what's this hmm number 11 in Italy the
song doesn't work that the problem the
records cook tell my problem is you have
never understood me and what I have to
go through you know what I should have
sex you where you left me I'm glad I
left it means I can maintain some
objectivity and yourself and those in
myopic what's the world get in the
studio makes you music or don't I don't
care well when your money runs out do
your worst
in fact take me to court you say into
contracts with me years ago so I'll
still be collecting my 20% along after
you've killed yourself
[Music]
when Roque was young me and Suzi had so
much fun Oh
[Music]
and skill mount stones
[Music]
[Music]
this film is Ellen's magical retelling
of his own life you serious about
wanting to be a rock and roller yeah
from a young age he was a true musical
prodigy it's amazing that this
working-class kid
is now one of the biggest icons in the
world music for the young boy pulled
them out of a very unhappy childhood and
off the table stop making that noise and
that opened the door to a world full of
infinite possibilities
because of the nature of who aranese the
storytelling allowed us to totally
indulge in fantasy and imagination
[Music]
the story is surreal but really there's
a bold piece of filmmaking this is more
than just a biopic it's exactly how an
Elton John story should be told it had
to be as honest as possible the lows
were very low but the highs were very
high that's how I wanted the film to be
you can be anyone you want Elton John I
just hope you realize you're choosing a
life of being alone forever
the pan the joy sorrow
he's gonna answer songs are people love
that's your gift
just bring the greatest joy of my
professional life making his film
I found the process of inhabiting Elton
John and his wardrobe incredibly DeRozan
Julian day is definitely the most
brilliant designer I've ever worked with
he's incredibly collaborative and he
understands the relationship between
with the costumes and performance what
we talked about was using the basis and
Elton's clothes to create our own look
for him
costumes and brilliance now can you even
play the piano in those it just brings
the fun to life maybe I should have
tried to be more ordinary you would
never ordinary there's over 50 pairs of
shoes there's over 50 pairs of glasses
is a massive massive amount of material
I really loved the yellow brick road
outfit I obviously looked at The Wizard
of Oz so he's got blue suit with ruby
red shoes on made of Swarovski crystals
the shirt is made of silver fabric which
is like the Tin Man
he's got straw hat on for the Scarecrow
and a big fake fur coat for the lion
[Music]
when I do a show even now 20 minutes
before I go on I choose my outfit and
until then I don't become elf and then
while I put my outfit on I'm in the park
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there are moments in a rockstars life
that define who he is where there was
darkness there is no you and it's going
to be a wild ride
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]